un nuevo secuestro masivo golpeó a
nigeria hombres armados irrumpieron en
un internado raptando a 42 personas y
asesinando a un estudiante y a la exacto
llorando adiós
estamos orando a dios para que sean
liberados pronto estamos llamando a la
policía para brindar más seguridad para
que no vuelva a suceder la zona donde se
produjo el secuestro es acá gara en el
noroeste del país un lugar donde no
tiene presencia habitual boko haram pero
si suele sufrir ataques terroristas
todavía no se sabe nada de los
desaparecidos y ningún grupo insurgente
se ha atribuido la autoría las
autoridades han desplegado efectivos
militares para intentar recuperar a los
afectados
hemos pedido al gobierno federal que
despliegue todos los recursos mientras
buscamos todas las opciones para
garantizar el regreso seguro de las
víctimas de los incidentes
los secuestros son una práctica habitual
en el norte de nigeria aquí
boko haram un grupo fundamentalista
islámico está en guerra contra el estado
nigeriano el 11 de diciembre de 344
estudiantes fueron raptados en la región
de katsina aunque seis días después la
mayor
ellos fueron liberados su secuestro más
conocido quizás sea el de 276 niñas en
abril de 2014 la noticia dio la vuelta
al mundo y aunque más de un centenar de
ellas consiguió huir o fueron liberadas
todavía hay decenas en paradero
desconocido